[Música]
el presidente de eeuu joe biden aseguró
estar convencido de que su homólogo
vladimir putin ya tomó la decisión de
invadir ucrania en mandataria esta
audiencia asegura que el ataque puede
producirse en los próximos días y
reiteró su amenaza de sanciones
económicas y diplomáticas
en medio de disturbios y enfrentamientos
la policía de ottawa detuvo al menos 70
manifestantes que hace semanas mantienen
bloqueos para rechazar las restricciones
por el cob y 19 que llevaron al primer
ministro canadiense justin crudo a
recurrir a la ley de emergencia
y california busca controlar y demandar
a los fabricantes de armas de asalto
emulando una ley de texas elaborada para
limitar los abortos el proyecto de ley
permitiría a los ciudadanos demandar a
los fabricantes de la misma manera que
tejas les permite demandar a los
proveedores de servicios de interrupción
del embarazo
hola bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
informativa de france 24 dedicada a las
principales noticias del continente
americano soy santiago y ahí comenzamos
con información sobre las denuncias
dirigidas por el gobierno de eeuu hacia
rusia por un eventual ataque de moscú a
kiev el presidente de yo vaivén aseguró
estar convencido de que rusia ya decidió
invadir ucrania el mandatario afirmó
además que el ataque podría producirse
en cualquier momento incluso durante los
próximos días y reiteró su amenaza de
sanciones económicas y diplomáticas
masivas contra rusia si decide invadir
baiden advirtió que eeuu y sus aliados
occidentales están más unidos que nunca
para garantizar que rusia pague el
precio de una eventual invasión
tenemos razón para creer que las fuerzas
rusas están planeando e intentarán
invadir ucrania en los próximos días
creemos que atacará en la capital kiev
una ciudad de 2,8 millones de personas
inocentes un tipo
estamos denunciando los planes de rusia
no porque queramos un conflicto sino
porque estamos haciendo todo lo que está
en nuestro poder para eliminar cualquier
razón que rusia pueda dar para
justificar la invasión de ucrania no se
equivoquen si rusia siguió adelante con
sus planes será responsable por una
catastrófica e innecesaria guerra por
elección world choice y aumenta la
atención en ottawa canadá a epicentro de
manifestaciones y bloqueos contra las
restricciones por el gobi 19 desde hace
ya tres semanas la policía que ya había
advertido a los camioneros que
protagonizan el paro sigo a cabo
detenciones y remolque de vehículos las
autoridades confirmaron que al menos 70
personas fueron arrestadas
la policía de ottawa pasa a la acción
las autoridades confirmaron el arresto
de decenas de manifestantes en la
capital canadiense al tiempo que
remolcaron aproximadamente dos docenas
de camiones que seguían bloqueando
importantes vías de la ciudad esto con
el fin de terminar con las protestas de
tres semanas iniciadas por los
camioneros que rechazan las
restricciones por el kobe 19 y venden
incluso esta mañana a todos los
manifestantes ilegales se les dio muchas
oportunidades de marcharse hasta las 15
horas de hoy hemos detenido a 70
personas se les ha acusado de múltiples
y diversos delitos incluido el de daños
y perjuicios
cientos de policías se desplegaron
algunos con equipos antidisturbios en
los alrededores del parlamento
canadiense bloqueando su vez rutas
aledañas con el fin de evitar el paso de
alimentos y combustible para los
camioneros algunos manifestantes se
entregaron pero otros se mostraron
desafiantes
esto es repugnante esto es absolutamente
ridículo detener a la gente en una
asamblea pacífica en la que tenemos
derecho de estar aquí incluso con la ley
de emergencia
el jueves por la tarde la policía de
ottawa había anunciado una acción
inminente hoy los oficiales señalaron
que trabajarán día y noche hasta que
restablezcan completamente el orden
amparados por la ley de emergencias
invocada por el primer ministro justin
trudeau quien endurecido el tono lanzado
advertencia sobre las consecuencias para
quienes no obedezcan y ha calificado los
bloqueos como una amenaza para la
economía canadiense
y vamos ahora a eeuu porque un nuevo
proyecto de ley en california permitiría
a los ciudanos demandar a los
fabricantes de armas de asalto de la
misma manera que tejas les permite a sus
residentes demandar a los proveedores de
servicios de aborto el gobernador gavin
newson respaldo la legislación de 1594
que permitiría a los ciudadanos hacer
cumplir la previsión estatal para las
armas de asalto el funcionario se basa
en una ley de texas que permite a los
ciudadanos hacer cumplir la prohibición
de abortos que sólo están permitidos
hasta la semana 6 de gestación newson
presentó su apoyo también como un reto
para la corte suprema que permitió la
entrada en vigor de la controvertida ley
texana a pesar de ser violatoria de la
normativa federales sobre el aborto
vamos a permitir que todos ustedes hagan
cumplir las normas reglamentos y leyes
del estado de california y creo que eso
es algo bueno si texas puede usar una
ley para prohibir el derecho de la mujer
a elegir y poner su salud en riesgo
nosotros usaremos la misma ley para
salvar vidas y mejorar la salud y
seguridad de las personas en el estado
de california en pro de health
monsters california avanzamos con más
noticias en france 24 la ex policía
estadounidense kimberly poder fue
sentenciada este viernes a dos años de
prisión por el asesinato ocurrido en
abril de 2021 el afroamericano don't you
ride durante un control vehicular la
gente alegó haber confundido su pistola
taser con su arma de fuego mientras que
la madre de la víctima acusó al sistema
de justicia de asesinar nuevamente a su
hijo con una pena tan corta el informe
es de andrea dama ya hay un veredicto
que provocó ira a los familiares de don
t y wright la ex agente de policía
estadounidense de kimberley potter
condenada por homicidio involuntario fue
sentenciada a dos años de prisión
montcourt la sentencia y la decisión de
esta corte es que usted será puesta bajo
custodia del comisionado de correcciones
por un periodo de 24 meses
deberá cumplir dos tercios de este
periodo estando 16 meses en prisión y un
tercio en libertad condicional asumiendo
que no se cometa ninguna ofensa
disciplinaria o violación de libertad
condicional kerr y wright la madre del
joven que murió en manos de la ex agente
de policía criticó el veredicto ya que
había pedido la sentencia más severa
posible que no
tiempo del asesino a mi hijo él murió
del 11 de abril hoy el sistema de
justicia lo asesinó de nuevo me senté
allí a mirar con mi corazón adolorido
el watch
hice mi declaración de impacto de la
víctima que me llevo tanto tiempo
escribir y la red escribí una y otra vez
para no obtener una respuesta del juez
en absoluto
el 11 de abril de 2021 donde wright de
20 años fue detenido por kim potter en
los suburbios de la ciudad de
minneapolis por llevar un ambientador
colgando ilegalmente del espejo
retrovisor de su automóvil y la ficha de
registro del vehículo estaba vencida
donde tenía además una orden de arresto
por porte ilegal de armas el joven trató
de huir y potter disparó con su arma de
servicio que asegura haber confundido
con su pistola eléctrica el caso
conmovió a todos eeuu además fue el
mismo día en que se realizó el juicio
contra el ex policía derecho bing que en
mayo de 2020 asfixió con su rodilla a la
prestada unidense george cloud lo que
desató una ola de manifestaciones en
varias partes del mundo y en noticias de
américa latina' el presidente de
brasilia bolsonaro sobrevoló el lugar
del trágico deslizamiento de tierra en
petrópolis en el estado de río de
janeiro que deja el momento más de 100
personas muertas mientras los vecinos
buscan a la escena desaparecidos en
medio de riesgos de nuevos deslaves una
imagen de intensa destrucción describió
bolsonaro quien recién llegado de su
viaje a rusia y hungría sobrevoló en
helicóptero las zonas afectadas
acompañado por varios de sus ministros
el mandatario brasileño aseguró que
aliviará el sufrimiento de los locales y
ofreció ayuda para la ciudad
ubicamos un área donde ha habido una
destrucción intensa también vimos áreas
con casas destruidas y daños causados
por la erosión
[Música]
es casi una imagen de guerra
lamentablemente pudimos ver la gravedad
de lo que sucedió aquí en petropar
veamos
y la compañía petrolera española repsol
afirmó que retiró ya el 98 por ciento
del crudo vertido en las costas peruanas
el pasado 15 de enero en aguas del
pacífico peruano la multinacional
anunció además que está comprometida a
largo plazo con la recuperación de las
áreas y poblaciones afectadas por el
derrame que afectó 106 kilómetros
cuadrados del litoral peruano el
presidente de repsol en perú jaime
fernández-cuesta aseguró que entre plaza
y mar no debería quedar más del 2% del
crudo que se derramó según repsol fueron
10 mil 400 barriles aunque para el
gobierno de pedro castillo fueron 11 mil
900 tras la etapa de limpieza
entraremos por supuesto en todos los
estudios medioambientales necesarios
para acometer las labores de
rehabilitación que sean necesarias para
dejar el ecosistema y el litoral peruano
en su estado natural
de esta manera llegamos al final de otra
emisión informativa pero recuerden que
pueden ampliar todas estas noticias y
conocer muchas más en nuestra página web
france 24 junto con gracias por
acompañarnos y sigan junto a nosotros
[Música]